[Music]
give us a sign
yeah we heard you oh i never done this
in vr
you can't yeah
he's unreal okay i'm a little slow
you're so much taller than me it's not
fair
hey catch
you can keep items grab it and grab it
right right now grab him grab my
basketball bro
try and grab it try and grab it try and
grab it
don't touch me there
you're gonna press as you let go it's
kind of broken all right all right let's
play let's
do play this is all stupid i'm gonna
teach you math
no stop
[Laughter]
i like how this is default i'm just like
all right dorothy smith
all right are we ready to go in oh god
it feels like it's actually raining
i don't want to do you have an umbrella
i got you bro
i got you bro thank you all right don't
let the radio get wet
you're not blocking me okay careful
careful jay
don't upset the ghosts oh damn this is
spoopy
in vr this is actually spoopy we know
you're here
we come for all your belongings yeah
hell yeah
[Music]
oh god you scared me based we're going
to get over the toothpaste
you understand she hates dental hygiene
yeah all right and i'll do
our style her hair
is that bad oh oh oh
uh usually then why are you leaving me
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
please way scarier in vr when you died i
got really scared hey
it's okay i'm leaving no it's okay no
it's okay
don't no it's not okay no it's not
it sucks and you know it oh i can't
stick my head all the way through
oh hi hey we made five bucks all right
sure
10 bucks this is going to be a tough one
uh yeah roger roger
uh looking good because it's smooth
clear and filled with ducklings over
that's pretty epic uh bring me a
duckling
um roger that roger roger
okay
stop taking pictures of pictures this is
why i'm dying you live
okay oh this spooky it's teleported
oh you picked the school the big one oh
god it's massive isn't it
okay r.i.p smokey r.i.p to a legend
split up that way with me yeah that's a
great idea
i'll just keep my radio and my thingy on
at all times
on my belt i'll go live
uh that's a big roger there jimbo uh
i'll head in through every door i see
roger that jimbo over are you still here
uh we're in the same room we're in the
same
we're in the same room
hey what's up hey what's up secret
handshake remember
that doesn't work okay i can't do it hey
let's take your handshake
you're the imposter why is it blinking
jack oh i thought you said this place
was safe
i'm not gonna die again i'm not gonna
die again do not come near me nancy
i'm not [ __ ] doing this you gotta
make yourself
big it's like a bear oh oh
we're big and scary
[Music]
oh my voice is also large
yep yeah we're crazy
we have one more shot all right why do
you keep taking pictures of nothing
is there a ghost in this room what was
that did you hear that
i swear i was you come on i just hear
your dogs hey guys
oh jesus stop leave
i was the ghost i got possessed for a
second it's so weird
did you just waste our last picture
are you out there and can you kill my
partner i heard footsteps
i'm using you as shield
[Music]
stop okay i'm freaking the ghost down
stupid ghost doesn't even care about
nancy
there nice
nice is there a ghost in here
dude dude
[Laughter]
that's great nancy johnson can suck it
that lord
hey how's it going you got a little
smudge on you
this is scarier than anything the game
is showing us
whoa what the [ __ ] is this that's a
parabolic microphone
from like a country away yeah
i bet it sounded really loud i whispered
into it i bet it sounded really loud
oh a head mounted camera did i did i put
did i put it on
oh [ __ ] you do you have it on my head
dude oh yeah
look at this you're on camera i can't
see myself for some reason but
yeah that's sick all right i got an idea
you go in
okay i'm [ __ ] ready i got a
flashlight i got a head camera
i got a [ __ ] thermometer all right
get out there i got all day
what a [ __ ] idiot he's gonna die
guarantee it
kenneth martin what a dumb name dude
all right um he needs help i'm gonna go
in and
i'm gonna go in and gum here's your
pickles
what's going on
than coming in my notebook we came for
your pickles
and we're not leaving without them
kenneth martin
this ain't no game it's janet i i know
what i read jack
we got freezing temperatures in here
what was that he said yes
so what does that mean does that mean we
can get the pickles or not
[Music]
oh it's getting close it's getting close
that's up your ass
when you keep getting pictures of
nothing okay kenneth
morrison martin if you're so smart
then why are you dead i don't oh i use
it in my hand
look at doll i see it oh
[Music]
what if we kissed by the ouija board
hey jack well we got ems
too oh jesus
kenneth what does kit 6 mean
oh
oh god the fan scared me what the [ __ ]
dude
i'm done i'm leaving
okay
jack come back please
[Music]
no oh god he is dead
oh my
[Music]
[Laughter]
dude that was so scary
oh so scared for you it was scary for me
you left me
i didn't leave anybody i went out
together i went out to look at the
camera yeah
and the door locked is entirely your
fire
three wishes really wishes
i wish
i wish pewdiepie was shorter
it reacted to your spanish oh oh they
wrote my book while it was on my arm
wait i can't read what does that say
[Music]
suck you
liabe
[Applause]
so we don't have to go far at all from
maria garcia
where where where where is she i see the
shadow
what the [ __ ] i saw the one mario garcia
i don't know i don't know
she spoke spanish my god
that was in spanish though oh you speak
spanish wow oh
i don't like that it was right in my
ears can i take a photo of myself i'm
bringing spirit box
it's probably [ __ ] the teacher okay
i'll put the lights on for you
not nice if you [ __ ] die for the five
seconds
if you can die for the five seconds that
i'm gone i'm gonna kill you
[Music]
what's happening
what happened
oh my god you got her get out of here it
sucks
i left you for two seconds yeah
and this is what happens oh you got a
great picture of it holy [ __ ]
that's that oh god that's spooky my for
me it's over here
damn it's so cool to see it in vr
actually it looks like a real photo you
got to like bless yourself
yeah bless yourself with a glow stick
and then you
now we may cross the threshold did i do
it right
see no you didn't you didn't bless
yourself properly so i couldn't cross
the barrier
yeah what was it kenneth anderson
hey guinea anderson this is a sick ass
product
cool all right put that on facebook
since i had to use my own oh bro bro
you've gotta try this recipe i'm making
you just gotta try it
[Music]
why does it taste like oranges hey let's
try this [ __ ] car dude
okay that pose is uncomfortable
jesus [ __ ] christ
it's okay it's okay i'm sorry i'm sorry
hey
hey hey h
i heard you laughed
jack are you there
what the [ __ ] was that what the [ __ ] was
that
no i'm actually [ __ ] [ __ ]
this
[Music]
no
[Applause]
[Music]
oh is he actually dead i think he
actually [ __ ] died oh
no oh i don't like that okay it's not a
joke anymore okay
i was just [ __ ] around before oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] where did he die
oh god felix no
no my boy
i'm not scared of ghosts
yep okay okay that's cool epic
what do we got what are we dealing with
oh yeah [ __ ] rave the hell no
not dealing that [ __ ] felix i'm sorry
i did it me all alone i'm amazing
yeah man
well i sold the case i don't care
yeah i was messing in the closet and i
was making sounds and then suddenly you
were like i'm dead i'm dead and i
thought it was you
joking scared of me your body was dead
alright guys thanks for watching see you
next time
[Music]
you